promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ProMix cité l'émission
qui vous parle de la place des femmes
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui
focus sur la santé des femmes moins bien
prises en charge que les hommes c'est ce
que nous dit un rapport du Forum
économique mondial lors de sa dernière
édition à Davos alors certes les femmes
vivent plus longtemps mais dans des
moins bonnes condition précisément parce
que la recherche leur accorde une
attention moindre que ce soit au niveau
des diagnostics les femmes seraient
diagnostiqués plus tard dans 700
maladies mais aussi au niveau des
traitements les inhalateurs pour
l'asthme seraient par exemple plus
efficaces sur les hommes investir dans
leur santé doit donc être une priorité
nous dit le forum qui précise que chaque
dollar investi rapporte 3 dollars de
croissance tout simplement parce que les
femmes guéries reviennent sur le marché
du travail à terme cela permettrait de
stimuler l'économie mondiale de 1000
milliards de dollars par an d'ici 2040
le forum qui promet d'investir 55
millions de dollars pour la santé des
femmes voilà promic cité c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
public
SNA promixité vous a été présenté par
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle